alors je reçois maintenant à un auteur
qui a défrayé la chronique lors de cette
rentrée littéraire qui s'appelle
christine angot et qui a écrit l'inceste
c'est chez stock
bonsoir michel bultel meilleur ami de
jean tiberi david hallyday le chanteur
de tu ne m'as pas laissé le temps
ils sont là clémentine célarié qui est
venu amical bon ce soir
et dieudonné qui sera président le
premier prétendant république métis en
france
et sinon nous avez montré votre livre la
caméra je vais enlever votre photo
puisque vous êtes là toute façon donc
j'ai pas la peine que je laisse la photo
sur la couverture c'est un taux ridicule
voilà c'est sérieux la couverture ans et
voilà zoom zoom mon garçon voile bon
vous voulez est ce qu il faut pour nos
amis téléspectateurs que vous résume y
ait un petit peu le bouquin même si
c'est pas facile
vous diriez quoi vous m'obligez valvert
déjà si j'avais si je pouvais le dire
comme ça en trois secondes ou en trois
mois
c'était pas la peine oui c'était pas la
peine
ce que ce qui est ce qu'il y à écrire
c'est c'est justement c'est ce qui c'est
ce que les gens peuvent pas comprendre
c'est ce que à un moment donné on essaye
d'expliquer à quelqu'un ou à plusieurs
personnes à la suite ou à plusieurs
personnes ensemble et puis on se rend
bien compte qu'il capte rien vraiment
rien donc là comme au bout d'un moment
c'est quand même un peu insupportable de
se dire bah oui ça passe pas
donc donc c'est là qu'il faut écrire
donc je vous voulez que je fasse le
travail idiot de résumer votre bouquin a
finalement écrit être idiot sérieux dans
mon idiot de jésus mais cache pas qu'au
mali fier d'eux sans égal vous racontez
votre style vous racontez votre inceste
non voilà j'étais sur des voix contre ça
et votre rupture avec une femme aimée
pendant trois mois
là non ben voilà j'en étais sûr bah oui
c'est normal
non parce que si vous voulez non c'est
déjà sur la manière de dire mais bon c
c'est racoleur vous trouvez non pas du
tout non c'est pas la question d'être
racoleur c'est enfin j'ai pas ça pas
tellement d'importance que je sais pas
si c'est racoleur pas racoleur
séparément histoire c'est de dire que je
raconte mon inceste
comme si j'avais déjà un inceste qui
m'appartenait et comme si ensuite je
m'amusais à le raconter
même si on pouvait raconter les choses
or moi je raconte rien j'écris et je ne
suis pas quelqu'un qui écrit quelque
chose vu quelqu'un qui écrit ja donc je
peux pas écrire un inceste encore moins
le mien et je vais pas écrire une
rupture 20 j'écris et puis à partir de
là il ya des choses qui devant une
machine qui sont là et puis et tout ce
qui est j'écris moi j'écris moi mais
c'est pas la même chose que de dire je
raconte moi par exemple vous arrivé là
oui oui oui je suis moi je suis je suis
franchement pas que j'ai pas lu le
bouquin je veux dire ça me donne envie
de le lire
ouais ben laden dans le 19ème non mais
c'est pas grave je viens
non mais on est obligé de dire ça
l'écriture c'est une aventure en fait
comment ça les gens tous ont commencé
cette aventure c'est un mot qui me va
bien de dire ça par exemple que c'est
une aventure est d'autant que c'est une
aventure qui concerne la personne qui
qui écrit l'écriture mais c'est aussi
une aventure qui concerne ceux qui sont
en mesure de recevoir vous ne pas
recevoir donc c'est aussi une aventure
un moment qui devient collective et
voilà ce que je que je pourrais en dire
c'est pour ça que ça peut pas être mon
truc machin mont asama rupture mot même
mon livre et nous voilà bien c'est bien
ton 10 david tu es le meilleur tu mois
sur non mais non faut être au moins deux
couacs ouais ouais ouais je peux pas
être seul non c'est quoi alors c'est
quoi alors qu'est ce qu'on peut dire il
ya à la fois c'est un saint cyr non non
d'abord ce qu'il faut dire c'est que ce
qu'on appelle l'autographe i c'est à
dire que vous vous mettez ça m'a
beaucoup de difficulté avec ça c'est bon
soir non parce que c'est normal parce
que j'ai des difficultés avec tous ouais
donc
c'est normal donc si vous voulez quand
on dit autographié ou auto fiction et
cetera ça veut dire aussi qu'on se prend
pour personnes âgées devraient vous avez
choisi un personnage puisqu'on vous
regardez la seule chose c'est que s'il
n'y a pas de perso je suis pas un
personnage je suis pas un personnage
c'est pour ça que c'est difficile pour
moi
là maintenant parce que en fait ya juste
la langue qui raconte quelque chose
c'est juste du langage c juste dit c'est
juste dire donc c'est pas un personnage
sinon moi je serais un perso un
personnage et ça c'est pas possible pas
peur je me vois moi me réduire un
personnage c'est pas possible parce que
c'est très réducteur
ça serait un double serait comme si je
me dédoubler or je me dis double pas du
tout il ya quelque chose au contraire
qui s'étend dans le livre suivait du dos
moi je comprends pas ce que le la pudeur
j'aime bien cette pudeur moi parce que
c'est par laisser briser un silence et
là en l'occurrence une oeuvre
personnelle
c'est vrai que c'est très tôt est très
difficile de venir en parler ça doit te
on veut dire quand même difficile on
peut dire quand même que bon vous
raconter à la fois une aventure qui a
duré trois mois
une aventure homosexuelle qui a duré
trois mois j'essayais dix ans le disons
le camp même nom ce n'est pas parce que
sinon j'ai pas lu le bouquin et que vous
racontez il ya le récits s'entrecroisent
avec le récit d'un inceste
oui on peut dire ça quand même oui enfin
cette cdci tu sors de deux mots de dire
de récits de trucs comme ça on va pas
revenir sur tout ce que ces danses rétro
mosquée mais oui il ya effectivement un
moment une association qui est faite
entre le terme d'inceste et entre le
terme d'homosexualité et puis non elle
au milieu qu'est la wii
la fête de noël voilà donc c'est vrai
que ça ça ça vient se rencontrer
l'inceste son homosexualité dans ce
livre en fait quand on lit le bouquin on
se demande d'abord si c'est de la
fiction si c'est de l'auto fiction si
c'est du témoignage on n'en sait rien en
fait c'est ce qui fait le charme du
livre en plus je vous le concède mais
aisément macy s dès lors du témoignage
ça alors là vous vous doutez bien que
c'est la dernière chose qu'ils puissent
plus fois non quoique vraiment non parce
que sinon c'est pas possible
parce que c'est pas possible à ce que
s'ils n'auraient pas d'écrivain un
écrivain c'est pas un témoin de rien du
tout c'est juste un écrivain quand on
voit une fille dans le bouquin qui
s'appelle comme vous qui est voué qui
avoue ce que vous allez skate avoué dans
ce bouquin la première question à se
poser c'est est-ce que ces vécus ou pas
mais ça c'est pas la question n'est pas
là la question c'est à dire que c'est de
la littérature ses troupes puisque vous
êtes venu en fait à l'émission de
peut-être si je peux me permettre de
voir c'était de dark est ce que vous
auriez à nous dire de solutions pour
faire et c'est même pas si je vais me
rendre mais écoutez c'est très simple
tout à l'heure en attendant je me disais
mais qu'est ce que c'est ce livre je ne
sais je ne bosse je sais pas et je
disais je disais aux personnes qui m'ont
accompagné je disais mais c'est pas
compliqué je vais m'appuyer sur les
questions qui va me poser je vais bien
me poser des questions donc je m'appuie
sur les questions qui me pose pas de
questions je m'appuie sur les questions
qui me posent
voilà c'est la meilleure chose à faire
parce que sinon qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est du discours qui peut être
politique ou qui peut être littéraire et
d'un coup on dit moi j'ai un truc à
balancer je le balance
bon voila mon livre c'est tac tac tac le
valence faut que je fasse passer ce
message
il n'y a pas de message il ya une seule
chose possible à mon avis si
effectivement vient à la radio à la
télévision n'importe où c'est de voir ce
que la personne qui peut poser une
question ou une autre personne peut
envoyer
est ce qu'on peut voilà à partir de là
ce qui peut être communiquée quelque
chose quand même dans ce que vous avez
écrit à la communication l'écriture
c'est pas la faute des données alors
quelque chose à de données oui oui voilà
ça m'a fait du mal à le formuler la
question je trouvais que je formule pas
bien bien
ccc méthodique sûr que vous êtes
il sort de rigueur alors ici de francs
très précis sur exactement ce que vous
avez envie de dire c'est précise rien a
vite dit assez surpris le faire pour moi
n'aurait pas dû lui rien dire mais c'est
ça il faut si on parlait tout à l'heure
de briser des aryens et à rien et yark
yark même s'il en est rien à la wii est
la risée à mai pour briser le silence
il ne faut rien dire voilà il faut parer
m vous parlez alors je manquais dimanche
26 ans va être page 26
vous ne dormez attendait il m'a demandé
un truc intéressant comme moi qui vais
demander si je pensais écrire un autre
livre
oui je sais tout vu de tous les passions
je vous pose volant mais seulement 8e
libre je n'ai jamais dit que c'était le
premier je me demande s'ils voulaient
ils sont ensemble
il y en a déjà qui est en train de
s'écrire messieurs ouais ouais c'est moi
ça me dérangera que vous réagissiez
comme ça moi j'ai invité souvent eric et
ramzy dans l'émission c'est pareil je
sais pas qui c'est on ne sait pas bien
alors nom vous dit page 26
parce que c'est là où quand il ya des
questions que nouveau clip soulève en
dehors de la qualité du texte la qualité
du caire 10 h 26 moi-même à 14 ans je
vais devenir écrivain je voulais
démarrer très fort j'ai pensé à
l'inceste
j'essaie de lui mon père donc voilà je
veux dire c'est on se demande pour ça
qu'on se demande on se dit est ce que je
remarque que c'est dû enfin moi je me le
demande
est ce que c'est de la création la
l'horaire est ce que tu avais invité sa
pose la question alors du marketing
est ce que si on veut vendre vraiment
quelque chose pourquoi pas alors
finalement peut-être que de vivre la
scène c'est une bonne méthode de
marketing oui ça c'est une vraie
question qui se pose dans la pause
oui à la planète faisons la rose et la
culture besoin la lra d'avoir dans un
bouquin quelqu'un qui dit moi j'essaie
parle en bourse et de l'humour d'inceste
non non c'est sérieux
je sais pas pour vous peut-être même un
nom de scène chaude que celle pompée est
pour tous les monarchistes
c'est de l'humour de cette phrase c'est
ça peut ça peut être de l'humour
disons que c'est si vous voulez c'est
simplement cette phrase là c'est je me
dis je me dis ben voila je vais dire ça
comme ça ils le diront pas me le dise
mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai que c'est on peut se poser la
question aussi de ces effectivement de
de l'argent quoi du business la mairesse
qui est fait autour d'un thème ceux qui
n'en ont peut pas se la poser
franchement on peut pas se la posent et
qu'on se la posent que des gens cela
pose donc que les gens je parle quand
ils ont ça en dit long sur les gens de
grand show biz votre imaginer une
seconde qu'une qu'une fille qui a 14 ans
va se dire tiens super plan je vais
séduire mon père et puis vint après
j'écrirai un livre ça s'appellera
l'inceste et ça se voit vendre à 50000
exemplaires si mon éditeur fait bien son
travail le fait bien
il le fait parce qu'il a un livre qui
lui permet de le faire bon mais cette
phase cette phrase est drôle moi je
trouve que c'est une réplique c'est une
réplique abusant du nominal un terrible
moi je sais bien je vais vous dire une
chose est sûre alors par exemple bon je
fais un peu de marketing lie alesi
description la quinine un gus page 27
formidable parce cela je vous laisse le
découvrir dans le livre page 64 jeu
léché moi c'est quand vous êtes avec la
file jeu léché moi cette mère dont
l'enfant est une chienne allait bien
c'est bien cela je suis folle vraiment
folle je ne toucherai qu'un petit public
de détraqués dans mon genre si je
continue je garde du public de détraqués
mon petit public de détraqués c'est ma
bouée voilà et vous savez il n'ya rien
j'ai reçu parmi les lettres que je j'ai
reçu ces derniers temps je reçus une
lettre absolument magnifique qu'il n'y
avait pas du tout de la drees et
téléphonie rien pour que je réponde et
où il y avait juste marquer donc où la
phrase c'était mon petit public ne sera
encaissé mabhouh est là dans le livre
celle que vous avez cités et la personne
qui me répond m'envoie sur une lettre
juste comme ça
christine je suis un morceau de votre
bouée assez bien ah bah c'est super
c'est super y'a pas l'adresse ya rien là
votre petit public de détraqués quand
même ça fait quoi 50000 personnes à bord
le moment qu'ils ont achetés non il ya
beaucoup d track est bloquée faisait la
guerre
c'est le titanic
alors je vais pas je vais pas dire tout
le bouquin mais enfin c'est vrai que il
ya cette relation donc par téléphone il
ya hiram page 206 là quand même
c'est violent allez-y
son père l'a forcé à manger les
clémentines sur son sexe ses l'inceste
il l'a sodomisée seulement après il
allait à la pharmacie acheter la baisse
digne et je voudrais savoir parce qu'il
fait rire david avec clémentine célarié
c'est parce qu'elle s'appelle clémentine
on rit parce que je pensais que tu
pensais avoir fait mentir il est bien
d'accord et oui mais voyez mais son père
de penser à changer des clémentines sur
son sexe non je me suis marré parce que
j'ai entendu les gens rigolaient parce
que je me suis dit tiens il aurait mieux
en parlait déjà plus continuer voilà
donc c'est vrai que c'est on rigole des
fois souvent de choses qu'on ne comprend
pas c'est vrai non mais c'est un sujet
quand même les voûtes est arrivé alors
pas renoncer pas vous terminez page 202
ces quatre pages avant l'inceste est
vraiment le livre où je me présente
comme une grosse merde tout écrivain
doit le faire au moins une fois dans sa
vie après on verra
veut dire quoi
après peut-être que c'est pas ça veut
dire bon déjà si vous lisez jusqu'à la
fin du paragraphe il ya quelque chose
qui dément immédiatement ça parce que ça
sert à rien de dire des choses si on est
dément pas après parce que les choses
sont jamais comme ça rigoureuse et est
vrai comme ça les opinions ça n'existe
pas on voit votre votre éditeur jean
marc roberts se dit en parlant de vous
bien entendu elle veut être célèbre
christine et j'ai tellement envie
qu'elle le soit faisait envie d'être
célèbre lui il a envie c'est normal
c'est votre éditeur parce que bon on
sait bien que l'éditeur
quand l'auteur touche différents ils ont
tous 90 mais vous vous avez vraiment
envie d'être c'est même moi j'ai envie
depuis que j'écris fin ça fait ça fait
15 ans et puis depuis mon premier livre
qui est sorti à dix ans j'ai envie de
pouvoir continuer à écrire et j'ai envie
que de surnager
j'ai envie que cette bouée là elles me
permettent de surnager et donc ce qui
est intéressant dans l'histoire de la
célébrité c'est que c'est qu'on n'est
pas tout seul
vraiment et qui est 150 lecteurs ou
qu'ils en aient 50000 mais ça change
énormément les choses énormément s'est
agrandi la boue et s'agrandit la boue et
ça fait que ben que même si vous dites
exactement les mêmes choses qu'avant ont
fait au moins semblant de vous écouter
donc bon parquet l'on serait dans un
bistrot tous les deux soirs j'écouterai
aussi parce que vous êtes assez rare non
assise
moi depuis modiano je n'avais pas vu un
auteur qui comme ça bon j'avais du mal à
saisir les choses et autres font assez
facile à elle vous dit souvent non non
non d'urgence pour ça non les gens qui
disent non mais moi j'ai maudit à nous
ça peut que me faire plaisir j'aime
beaucoup
depuis que vous êtes arrivé sur le
plateau vous n'avez pas sourit même ri
une seule fois ci qu'est ce qui vous
fait rêver qu'est ce qui vous fait rire
en bout sans tout le monde en penser les
missions qui me fait rêver vous c'est
pour ça que vous êtes là
l'humour le premier degré ah oui bah oui
c'était au premier degré ou dance est
marrant non elle va dire dit toujours
non non c'est pas ça mais afin qu'ils
aient toujours la question de delaunay
paris c'est invraisemblable ce genre de
questions vous fait rire et on fait un
rêve est enfin vous voyez ces gens ne
seront que maintenant on vous sent assez
assez comique assez assez figée cg je
suis figée
bah là non ça y est un coup ça vient
grâce à vous ce bouquin est vraiment
était destiné je dis pas à vous l'avez
fait sciemment tous les cas votre
éditeur quand il a vu arriver il a vu
tout de suite
ce livre était destiné à faire le
scandale de la rentrée que ça et
finalement toute la critique a chanté
ses louanges
toulon la liste formidable et sinon go
affiche ici vous savez bien enfin les
gens branchés les inrocks technique à ça
les gens qui font l'opinion libération
ne doit pas pas les autres mais ce qui
compte vraiment on dit c'est formidable
bond est-ce que c'est pas un peu gênant
finalement pour vous d'avoir été
acceptée aussi facilement par cette
critique est d'habitude et ça que je
vais vous dire quelque chose
c'est ce que bon il ya cette espèce de
deux choses là que vous dites qui est
juste a répondu je n'en sais pas quoi et
c'est bon et puis il ya la grande
question qu'on m'a posée sans arrêt les
meilleurs amis en général le dise
attention quand ça va retomber
ouais je vous dis demander une chose est
ce que vous avez pas peur finalement
maintenant
vous vous êtes transformé un peu en
vedette de la télévision un peu il ya un
côté médiatique dans tout ça un peu
phénomène de foire
et pendant ce temps là amélie nothomb
ben qui elle son chapeau et son côté
belge soleil jeudi les jurés contre les
belges mais avec son côté belge
finalement c'est elle qui passe pour
l'écrivaine vous embête pas ça alors que
je pense que vous êtes bien entendu bon
mais mais tout le monde pense comme vous
d'accord évidemment rien alors on va
baisser la lumière vous inquiétez pas
question mais c'était le mien on bouge
pas
[Applaudissements]
non
voilà je vous faire c'est le portrait
chinois vous connaissez le portrait
chinois chinois ces sites étaient une
fleur jeu sera un mobile aux myosotis si
j'étais un homme politique je serai
michel bulteau tout ça moi je vous faire
un anti portrait chinois
ouais si vous étiez un défaut vous
seriez quoi comme défaut elle va avoir
beaucoup de difficulté un jeu c'est pas
la décision ah oui voilà
si vous étiez une maladie une maladie se
serait forcément une maladie 201 oui tu
détiens dictateur à bas ce serait une
claire forcément tu y tiens avis la
vertu bonne réponse vous étiez un
supplice la conversation
si vous étiez une humiliation si j'étais
une humiliation
ce serait victime qu'on me dise que je
fais une victime et une infirmité pour
finir si vous étiez une infirmité cas
l'infirmité seriez-vous à aubin je suis
une affluence bien vous restez là tout
le monde reste là j'accueille notre
invité suivant nos klarsfeld
[Musique]
christine vous partez vous avez quelque
chose contre arnaud classe tél non mais
j'ai un truc à faire écouter alesi et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus